[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday
September 12th and I'm going to read you
from the first chapter of my new book
Paper Towns quick caveat this isn't
going to sound exactly like it'll sound
next year when it comes out because it's
still pretty rough your input is welcome
our subdivision Jefferson Park used to
be a Navy base but then the Navy didn't
need it anymore so it returned the land
of the citizens of Orlando Florida we
decided to build a massive subdivision
because that's what we do with land my
parents and Margo Roth Spiegelman 's
parents ended up moving next door to
each other just after the first houses
were built Margo and I were two before
Jefferson Park was at Pleasantville and
before it was a Navy base it belonged to
an actual Jefferson the Jefferson in
question was this guy dr. Jefferson
Jefferson dr. Jefferson Jefferson has a
school named after him in Orlando and
also a large charitable foundation and
the fascinating and unbelievable but
true thing about dr. Jefferson Jefferson
is that he was not a doctor of any kind
he was an orange juice salesman when he
became rich and powerful he just went to
court and had his first name change from
Jefferson to doctor capital D lowercase
our period Marga's parents were friends
with my parents and when we were a
little Margo and I would sometimes bike
through the coldest akhi streets to
Jefferson Park itself which was the hub
of the subdivisions wheel I always got
very nervous whenever I heard that she
was about to show up on account of how
she was the most fantastically gorgeous
creature that God had ever created that
afternoon she wore white shorts and a
pink t-shirt that featured a green
dragon breathing a fire of orange
glitter it is very difficult to explain
how awesome I found this shirt at the
time so we were 10 it was a steaming hot
day in March and Margo and I biked to
the park
she always biked standing up her arms
locked as she leaned above the
handlebars her purple sneakers a
rotating bore the sky was clear but the
air tasted acidic like it might storm
later at the time I fancied myself an
inventor and after we locked up our
bikes and began a short walk across the
park to the playground
I told Margo about an idea I had for an
invention called the ring later the ring
later was this gigantic cannon that
would shoot big colored rocks into a
very low orbit giving earth the same
kind of rings that Saturn has I still
think this would be an excellent idea
actually but it turns out that building
a cannon that can shoot boulders into a
low
orbit is kind of complicated we were
only a few steps inside the park when I
began to sense that the world was out of
order I'd been in that Park so many
times before that it was mapped in my
mind but I couldn't figure out what was
different that still happens to me I can
sense changes but I can't identify them
someone's wearing a new pair of jeans
and I say did you get a haircut Quentin
Margo said quietly she was pointing and
then I realized what was different
there was a live oak tree a few feet
from us thick and gnarled and
ancient-looking
that wasn't new but now now a guy
wearing a gray suit sat slumped against
the trunk I may not be a master of
observation but I was able to deduce
pretty quickly that the guy was dead on
account of how one he wasn't moving into
he was surrounded by a sizable amount of
blood which three seemed to originate
from somewhere inside his mouth which
itself was four open in a way that
mouths are generally not open not to
mention the fact that five there were
quite a lot of flies involved in the
whole scene he's dead Margo said as if I
couldn't tell I took two small steps
backward I remember thinking that if I
made sudden movements he might wake up
and attack me maybe he was a zombie
I knew zombies weren't real but he sure
looked like a potential zombie as I took
those two steps back Margo took two
equally small and quiet steps forward
his eyes are open
she said Margo we got to go home she
looked at me and said I thought you
closed your eyes when you died Hank I'll
finish reading this flashback on Friday
I'll see you tomorrow